the Supreme Court has said to announce
decisions Thank You Orrin this morning
that could change the way you are
represented in Washington the court is
expected to decide whether congressional
district maps in North Carolina and
Maryland are unconstitutional because
they are too slanted toward one
political party now will also rule on
the Trump administration's plan to ask
about citizenship in the 2020 census
opponents say a citizenship question
would discourage some people in minority
communities from filling out the census
leading to undercounting or other
inaccurate results CBS new director of
elections and surveys Anthony Silvan toe
is here Anthony why is the census case
so important
good morning Anthony well look the
census is critical to everybody first of
all it impacts federal funding for
everything from say schools and
hospitals to where disaster aid goes
thinks based in part on how many people
there are in a place but there's
political power at stake here too
because the census also determines how
many electoral college votes each state
will cast in presidential elections also
how many representatives each state gets
to sent to Congress and what parts of
those states that they come from that is
where those district lines are drawn now
in terms of estimates that people are
watching in states as these decisions
come down look for the impact possibly
in places like California in Texas maybe
Florida Georgia and a handful of states
in the Northeast that we think have
higher populations of undocumented
immigrants foreign-born populations or
people here on work visas now take a
look for example at California if you
take California's 55 electoral votes and
53 representatives now if folks don't
fill out the forms there and they get
what critics call an undercount
or Texas is 38 electoral votes and 36
representatives census comes back lower
in those states because people don't
fill out the forms that's not a
certainty but that would mean power
could shift away from those fast-growing
states and into others and that's the
key thing to watch as we go forward it
won't happen immediately what happened
in 2020 but you're watching power
struggles play out over the next 10
years starting maybe today so Anthony
when you think about the bottom line how
will these two cases these two
decisions the Census and the
gerrymandering Mandarin cakes impact
future elections well I think a lot of
it will start in the gerrymandering case
with how those district lines are drawn
what you see here on this map is
California's congressional district but
which parts of the states do
representatives come from well if those
states can draw lines that possibly
incorporate partisanship whether people
are Democrats or Republicans when they
draw those lines that could help
determine the balance of power in
congressional representation coming out
of those states and that's a key thing
to watch going forward Tony all right
Anthony thank you very much